مصائب تويتر تهبط بردا وسلاما على منصه
تمبلر المنصه بشعرها الذي يشبه التويتر
كثيرا تحاول ان تقتنص الفرصه
لتضخ الحياه في شرايينها من جديد
فبينما انسحب المعلنون من تويتر الشهر
الماضي بدا تمبلر حمله اعلانيه جديده
لتشجيع المستخدمين على العوده الى نظامه
الذي كان شائعا من قبل في ظل تغييرات
متواصله يعاني منها الطائر الازرق منذ ان
سيطر عليه الى الماسك في بدايه عام 2007
تم اطلاق منصه
لمؤسسها ديفيد كارت كواحده من نصات
التدوين الالكترونيه والتي لاقت اقبال
هائلا في تلك الفتره حيث وصل عدد مستخدمه
وبعد اسبوعين فقط من الاطلاق الى 75,000
مستخدم كما سجل فيه لاحقا
75,000 مدور
حتى وصل عدد المسجلين الى مليونين تمبلر
منصه تدوين الاجتماعي تسمح لمستخدميها
بالتدوين على شكل نص او صوره او ملفات
فيديو او روابط او اقوال او محادثه او حتى
ملفات صوتيه
يستطيع المستخدمون في تمبلر متابعه باقي
المستخدمين فتظهر تحديثاتهم على حساباتهم
الخاصه كما يستطيعون تفضيل او اعاده ارسال
التحديثات في الموقع كما هي الحال مع
تويتر
تمبلر يبسط منصته مرحبا ومن جديد
بالمستخدمين محاولا كسب ثقتهم ومن ثم جذب
المعلمين مع العمل على سحب البساط من تحت
اقدام تويتر الذي يقدمه هو الاخر فرصه من
ذهب لمنصات التواصل الاجتماعيه الاخرى
للعوده بل والمنافسه في خضم بحث
المستخدمين عن طرق جديده وسهله ومستقره
للتواصل